I always just did whatever I wanted.
Because I was young and I didn't care.
You're going to have to promise me something.
What?
That you won’t call the cops.
Um, hello. Ms. Carlile?
Mrs.
Ben Saunders.
Gardener extraordinaire.
Ready to get started.
Hey, Ben.
Something I can do for you, Mrs. Carlile?
Thank you.
Hey, you know how you could really really thank me?
Mind if I jump in the pool?
Are you a swimmer?
Never really get the chance...
...but I'm pretty good...
...at most physical stuff.
She’s a little out of your league don’t you think?
Here’s some advice.
All things in this world...
...are divided into groups.
Do not mix your groups.
Look, I don't have anything.
And I see your house and your car.
You have all these beautiful things...
...and they aren’t being taken care of.
You have no idea what it means...
...to a guy like me to take a dip into a private pool.
I’m in love with you.
It's all a game.
The whole world.
I'd like to report an illegal alien...
...in my neighborhood.
Only suckers choose not to play it.
You like her.
You want her.
You want me to cut her?
Until she bleeds all over?
She makes no difference to me.
It wants something that doesn’t belong to it.
What?
You.
Kinda overstayed my welcome.
Maybe you should go.
Do you want me to?